[Music]
[Music]
well I'm about out of water for water in
my greenhouse so I got to pump some
water up from the river to fill up my
tank go through a lot of water on hot
sunny days if I have a hot week I'll go
through almost two of these tanks in one
week so over 700 gallons of water in a
week I've got this tank here I can't
even see my water line anymore sigh I'm
just about out I don't have a well here
I tried putting wells in I can't get it
through the permafrost
so basically I've resorted to pumping
Yukon River water up into tanks that are
up in the air so I'm gonna go down put a
pump in my boat pump water up from the
river fill this tank up and then this
hose here comes out of my tank it goes
into my greenhouse there's enough fall
in the water enough weight here that I
don't have to run a pump I can just turn
on my spicket inside and I can water all
my plants
gonna help God kind of ironic I'm out
here right now helping 352 4 and gallons
of water up to my house and it's pouring
down rain
[Music]
hoping Yukon water plenty of water now
going to the gravity-feed I got
gravity-feed using up high I need some
times I'm living 100 miles south of the
Arctic Circle and I'm growing peppers
nice peppers look at that pepper that's
a beauty they can grow things in here
that I can't grow outside beans zucchini
tomatoes yeah beautiful cherry tomato
perfect this ready for me to eat that
may not be a big deal
down south in the lower 48 but that's a
real big deal to get fresh vegetables up
in Alaska in the bush I want a high
quality of life good food comfortable
living in an environment that I can do
things the way I want to do them I got
to go turn my pump off my water tanks
full greenhouse is nice and watered so
I'm good to go for another day
[Music]